hi everyone it's jerry here's another
interesting puzzle that i'd like to
share with you it's an end game study by
richard ready that was published in 1928
it's white to move if you'd like to go
ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white
okay the solution here is to not
initially
push your pawn up to e7 as the bishop
will be there to track it down
and well the king is just not going to
be fast enough to catch this black pawn
another faulty try would be king f7 or
g7 because well
he's just not going to be fast enough
any push once again the bishop's there
to track that pawn down
so what exactly
is the trick here well the first move
the solution of this one
is king e7
seems a bit odd of course obstructing
your own pawn but
it certainly will have its point
revealed soon enough
the initial intention is to once again
make use of f6 to track that pawn down
so black needs to push
king d6 it seems as though he's moving
away from this pawn but he is yet again
in a position to hunt him down
only this time by way of e5
g4
and now we push our pawn this is a very
key moment
forcing bishop b5
and now the point is revealed with
white's next move
king c5 comes all the way from f8
makes use of c5 to do what exactly
have two threats in mind one simply grab
the bishop and two
be in a position
to be inside of the box to track this
pawn down
what does what does black do here g3 we
would scoop up the bishop
white is the side who queens first this
would be a draw
and the other attempt here would be
let's say to move the bishop out of
harm's way
but now the king is getting to
this square here on d4 he is in fact
inside of the box he will be able to
catch this pawn if he continues to march
suppose king b7 simply king e4
king c7
king f4
the black king is almost there to scoop
that pawn up which would allow this
bishop to stay trained
on that g4 pawn and defend that pawn but
now would come e8 deflecting the bishop
away
we scoop that pawn up and this is of
course
a drawn position
i'd like to emphasize one key detail
here it's a very cool puzzle
again the main aim here was to make use
of c5
basically go straight into that square
e7 d6 c5 so that we can gain a tempo
against the bishop
notice after g4 if we are playing king
c5 at this point here instead of pushing
our pawn
notice how after king c5
g3 creates a new door
a new diagonal
for the bishop
now after e7 there's simply bishop here
there will be no tempo against the
bishop and black is the one who would
win
but again just to recap this here being
the solution
king e7 d6 c5
where he eventually gains a tempo
against the bishop
and we'll be in a position to hunt that
pawn down just in the nick of time here
with this deflection
e8 equals queen and then king takes pawn
so
that's all for this video feel free to
leave some feedback and let me know what
you thought of it
and i'll catch you in the next video
take care bye
you